follow him as soon as you can check out
the interview he did with me it was a
really really fun time oh yeah don't
don't get pervy hey reject nation that's
right I hit record Oh
I'm Perry Howard you guys can follow him
on instagram focus TV network has his
own show hashtag Harry and Kelley it's
an awesome talk show I was on it
recently we're gonna put the link for
the Youtube upload in the description
box go watch that interview Harry and
Ren would write a description of him is
awesome I showed him the trailer for
Christopher Robin before we started
filming Oh today we're gonna watch the
adventure and legacy videos that were
just recently uploaded by Disney
Christopher Robin is a film I'm greatly
looking forward to you you watched it
Winnie the Pooh growing up I did it was
amazing I got to give a patient the day
shout-out to someone really fast though
I'm gonna give a picture today shoutout
to james Stegen today james stallions is
a man who i greatly loved let me show
you a photo we took that was our last
google hangout we did together I love
this man and James you are an
inspiration and I wanted to give you a
shout out because I could see you ending
up like Christopher Robin one day kind
of lonely lost sense of childhood
wishing you had never lost a youthful
side of you and you kind of just resent
being an adult I cannot wait to see you
when you're at that point buddy that's
how much I love you see that's why
everyone wants a shout out I give
empowering words of wisdom let's watch
this ready I have to stay for work
life is happening now well let's see
[Music]
what you see
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like a G version of head just an
average twins D more didn't hear it yeah
[Music]
PG get tickets now
all right let's hop right into this
other one called legacy it's a feature
rat and then we'll talk about from
Disney's cartoons he's really alive as a
character and people's imaginations
however did you recognize me whoever
changed a bit the characters that's all
I generation my parents generation and
now this generation but growing up with
all the Baron my father's floorings
became a dear friend of mine when Walt
gave us the assignment to write songs
for the first Winnie the Pooh a short
film and here's so many years later very
special to be back in 100 Acre Wood well
I didn't expect to be here today doesn't
it hurt doing a great job of bringing
some of their archived characters to
life and is exciting to be involved in
Christopher Robin are they happy about
it when it comes back to him and the
difficult time in his life to save us to
save him he so speaks a lot of truth the
whole new generation is being introduced
to this beloved character is something
very exciting
open up this is a charming story of a
man finding his swim again and finding
that being the child I saw it really is
a lovely funny and adventure will come
out the better for it having seen it I
think
it's been hard to act with all these
fake things yeah you got to really use
your imagination yeah well it's very
apparent that his family's gonna die at
the end and Christopher Robin's gonna
end up very lonely that he's gonna kill
Winnie the Pooh yeah well other dolls or
he might end up in a mental institution
yeah they're not alive
Christopher they're stuffed animals even
do you hear yourself Christopher they're
not real they aren't they aren't real
they are real I guess in this world
maybe the trailers are all just miss
marketing it and yeah wouldn't the
family's just humoring him like this is
act like they're really talking
government be involved is not grounded
in reality so yeah we cannot compare you
know I don't want this fantasy crap
what's funny about these two marketing
stuff as opposed to like the other
trailer was the other trailer does kind
of have that sense of it feels a little
bit like a dramedy like you do have the
question to go is it crazy psychiatrist
are you all right yeah for Robin that it
feels a little bit dark
this one is more amplified he's involved
yeah they're fine the family vibe that
apathetic the first one's called
adventure so it has a little bit more
wacky humor a little bit more sense of
fun if you're gonna do this movie you
need to have that element of just having
a lot more fun that's true you know I
found odd is that they didn't really
include he or that much I thought he was
the comic relief or maybe he's too emo
yeah he commits suicide by the depressed
animal what a very realistic take of
this movie yeah yeah murders yeah he's
barely in the other trailers you have to
keep it grounded in a wayward it's
called Christopher Robin so the central
part is visible Robin and then if you're
gonna have one other character that you
really capitalized it has to be winning
the poop I'm sure we're gonna get plenty
of the other characters throughout the
film it's just a marketing purpose or
that
the adventure trailer in the featurette
i really feel like they're just honoring
the spirit of Winnie they are it's yeah
if you're not intellectual like me who's
analyzing all the plot a very great take
on the cartoon for sure no quite
absolutely and I love that because it
seems like it's gonna be a very obvious
art but one that I want to see I'm a guy
who's kind of cynical he doesn't adjust
well to being an adult he's probably
feeling resentful by the end of the
movie he'll be like Oh spirits not
everything's about was like the movie
hook meets Ted you know that's a great
way to put it I'm glad I invited you on
today this looks like a delightful time
and even McGregor you know you see a lot
of interviews the actors and they do
from a material for films and you could
tell when they don't really want it to
be a part of the film is did it for a
paycheck he seemed like he yeah he
actually enjoyed it you had to enjoy
filming this for three months talking to
yourself
yeah that's some things there oh
definitely I feel bad with how they're
dressed that's a great point this is
right here to analyze the logic not try
to be cynical I'm just trying to be
scientifically accurate seems like you
identify with Christopher Robin very
much your imagination flow alright guys
well you decided for Christopher Robin I
hope you are yes you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification Bell check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is music video coverage would
love to have you become a patron Oh
check today but more importantly give
Harry Howard a follow on Instagram
there's the district on me I love my
following follow him as soon as you can
check out the interview he did with me
it was a really really fun time oh yeah
don't don't get pervy